so president biden rescinded the trump  executive orders that basically sought  to ban tick-tock and wechat in the  united states which  you know if you're watching this that  probably would have affected your lives  the thing is  the trump executive orders never went  into effect judges in multiple lawsuits  had  issued injunctions that prevented those  executive orders from going into effect  and basically those executive orders  were  sort of unworkable because they singled  out specific  companies but ticktock and wechat are  not out of the woods replacing the trump  executive orders are the biden executive  orders that  don't single out a particular company  but instead purport to look at the  national security interest related to  all these apps so  if they are harvesting data for national  security issues potentially they might  still be  shut down even under the bite  administration so we'll probably see  tick tock  in court